warum hast du überhaupt so ein scheiß
kuscheltiere zu süß aussieht dass hier
das mit mikrofon thomas selber
nachdenken über dann dumme fragen
herzlich willkommen hier heute zu einem
neuen video auf einem kanal mal wieder
hier erzählt sie samt argumentiert like
dislike kann man nicht zurück war meine
bilder sind die geizig mit report 2009
ihr flutschfinger sie willkommen wir
heute auf jeden fall zu einem neuen
video auf einem kanal juli hinter der
kamera und hat zehn schätzfrage
rausgesucht und wir beiden müssen
schätzen dass die richtige antwort ist
auch die frage also los geht's wie viele
medien wurden schon in den sparten
verein schickt ich glaube ich weiß es
relativ genau geguckt auf deinem handy
dann ich hab ganz auf chat kontaktieren
ich sag 30.000 nächste frei hat ein
bisschen was mit biologie zu tun wie
hier winkt ein buckelwal in kilogramm
ich kenne nur den blauwal der buckelwale
schon mit einer der schwersten wahre
glaube sagt 30 doch das ist gut das ist
meine stimme wie 129.000 kilo
ddp direct das 33 mal sandra stimmt wie
lang ist das glied der 15 zentimeter
langen banalen schnecke 5 cm lange
bananen schnecke sicher so 32 15 meter
etwa fünf zentimeter
das ist tatsächlich 80 cm lang das
heisst es 5 5 mal so groß wie die
schnecke selbst der tennis größer ist
das gerät boras ist ihr gehalt ab wie
viele beiträge carola bei instagram und
mein gott jetzt die meisten von uns ich
sage 635 sagt 1809 sondern die breite
bis zum gegen solche leute wie viel
prozent der weltbevölkerung sind
linkshänder
das war ein prozent oder 5 prozent wie
du mich sagt 10
ich sag 20 mit wie vielen tagen hat
haben ihren status mein gott oh mein
gott 420 tagen ich sage seit 700 tagen
wie viele videos hat luca auf seinem
haupt kanal bei youtube hochgeladen
500 1 2806 und ihr guckt euch jeden tag
dieses geräts wie viele herz parat ein
regenwurm was ist ein erster 625 wie
viele buchstaben hat das habe jahren
schnell verweht worden fast für ideen
kommt ein top version euro alles
scheinbar bin ich sage
ich sag 200 auch die auf den punkt genau
zu sein ist schon vorbild der folio also
ich bekomm preis so dass die viele
städte gibt es in russland in die kein
ausländer rein darf also ich bin raus
sind nicht papst nun keine ahnung 0
du hast nur gesagt das ist meine
schärfste ok damit ja auch nicht sein
rad gewonnen dabei war ich aber nicht
zufrieden ich gewinne nicht gegen ich
habe mach doch nicht mittel mit dir mit
user ja damit will ich das video dann
nicht so beenden
[Musik]
dass du drauf und es regnet